german chancellor olaf schultz has
reacted to the reports of atrocities in
ukraine he says western allies will
impose more sanctions on russia in the
next few days
i call on president putin and on russia
to finally agree to a ceasefire
this is a horrible senseless war that
cannot be justified by anything
in the creek that has created endless
suffering and benefits no one
lost
it has to stop
in coordination with our allies we will
decide on further measures in the coming
days
president putin and his enablers will
suffer the
consequences and we will continue to
supply weapons to ukraine so that you
can defend itself against the russian
invasion
olaf short speaking there now let's
bring in dw's chief political editor
michele
chancellor said new measures are being
prepared in response to russia's
aggression in ukraine so what can we
expect there
well we can expect
the next the fifth measure uh package of
sanctions to be brought underway that
those are also the signals we're hearing
coming out of brussels because after all
it's the eu always acting alone even as
olaf schweitz was speaking those words
calling on vladimir putin to at least
agree to a ceasefire he knows that
calling on him to do anything won't get
him anywhere but the impression very
much here is and had the possibility to
put that question to hubbard
this morning what that sanctions package
could be and how it might have changed
over the weekend now that we've seen
this evidence of war crimes of potential
crimes against humanity he wouldn't
really be drawn on that but he did say
that the impression is that these
sanctions are working economic sanctions
are working and that that is now taken
into account when tailoring more
sanctions and that's really the emphasis
here and there's talk of specific
strategic goods being targeted more
individuals
i think that stands for oligarchs being
um targeted around the circle of
vladimir putin and cash flows being
interrupted those are the signals we're
getting here the red line still
maintains certainly germany is ruling
out a gas boycott for now
now germany's economy minister and vice
chancellor robert harbeck spoke to the
press a little while ago uh you were
there and his own party the
environmentalist greens is calling for a
full embargo on imports of oil and gas
from russia did he address that in that
press conference
yes and basically the reason why that
red line still stands from the german
side in that one doesn't want to go down
that route of simply cutting off
supplies the argument remains that that
would hurt germany would hurt europe
more than it would
hurt russia but there's a lot of
criticism coming also from other highly
dependent states
like poland for instance that the german
government is not decisive enough
also ukraine's ambassador here is
calling not just for more sanctions and
energy embargo he wants more weapons
frankly he wants a faster track delivery
of weapons now the german government is
very cagey we know that a lot of
rocket-propelled grenades have already
been delivered from the german side but
the flow of military goods is not as
swift and smooth as the ukrainians are
calling for here we heard habek the vice
chancellor and the head of the trade
ministry that has to give the green
light for weapons exports saying that he
is in favor of what he said unlimited uh
green light for those uh those strategic
those defense goods uh but for now it's
a lot of criticism from the ukrainian
side it's not fast enough and it's not
enough for them
two's chief political editor michelle
thank you michelle
reports of the latest atrocities are
adding pressure on western allies to
take more radical steps amid those calls
for a boycott of russian oil and gas are
growing louder over the weekend
germany's defense minister also said
such a step
needed to be discussed as europe
receives 40 percent of its gas from
russia germany's chancellor olaf schultz
rebuffed calls for a full ban saying it
would wreak havoc on the economy and
risk social unrest
all right let's unpack this with christy
platson my colleague at dw business uh
christy um the german chancellor saying
a ban
of uh gas deliveries from russia would
wreak havoc on the economy is he right
well he's certainly right in the sense
that germany's economy would feel the
impact of cutting off imports of energy
from russia but the jury's still out on
exactly how much of an impact this will
have we do have experts working on
modeling for this but they will admit
that this is a completely novel
situation for germany and that makes it
difficult to make a reliable forecast
now what we do know and what the
chancellor certainly is aware of as well
is that it's going to be industries like
the chemical industry the steel industry
energy intensive industries essentially
that work are going to be hit the
hardest uh were they were they to cut
off this energy supply and if anyone
who's familiar with germany's economy
knows that these are major players here
just last week we had uh industrial
groups coming out saying that if we were
to stop taking russian energy that they
could be closing shop within just a
matter of weeks so this of course could
be unemployment which could have a
ripple effect into further industries
and that's obviously very hard to
forecast and this is
certainly something the chancellor has
in mind
christie nevertheless calls for
targeting targeting russia's energy
sector they are growing we have poland's
prime minister saying that germany is
the main roadblock to tougher sanctions
on russia so how much longer will the
stance of the german government prevail
right well as you said we saw something
of a shift change just yesterday when
the defense minister came out and said
that the eu needs to consider banning
russian energy us issue basically saying
that this needs to be an option that's
on the table now at the same time on the
exact same day we saw an article out
quoting the finance minister saying that
he is still against this move so there's
certainly not um necessarily unity on
this uh at this point um now as we said
this is a very unique situation for
germany but they have something of a
benefit of still coming off of another
recent unique scenario and of course i'm
talking there about the coronavirus
pandemic and now what we saw during uh
that is that lockdowns and supply chain
issues meant a cut of 5 gdp in 2020 in
germany
currently the most pessimistic modeling
for this situation with russia shows a
cut of 6 so we can see that it's maybe
not
that different and that might be
something that the officials will be
thinking about now christy platson thank
you